>>> HEY.
ARE YOU GUYS FREE TO TALK?
>> MOLLY!
>> HEY, MOLLY.
>> COME ON IN.
WE'RE PLAGUE SOME VIDEO GAMES.
>> YOU WANT TO KNOW THE TRUTH --
>> WAIT, WHAT GAME IS THIS.
>> MOLLY 2 K 23.
>> IT'S REALLY FUN.
YOU PLAY AS MOLLY SHANNON
BOUNCING YOUR CAREER AS AN ACTOR
WITH RAISING A FAMILY.
>> AND THAT'S HOW I EMBARRASSED
MYSELF IN FRONT OF OBAMA.
>> OH, YOU JUST CRACKED JIMMY
UP.
>> THERE'S A GAME ABOUT MY LIFE?
>> OH, DUDE.
WE UNLOCKED AN NYU COMMENTMENT
SPEECH.
PRESS A TO GET KIDS -- OR PRESS
B.
>> THIS GENERATION IS A BUNCH OF
SNOWFLAKES.
>> CAREER SETBACK.
>> DAMN IT.
THAT MADE US DROP ALL OUR
TURNUPS.
>> WHAT ARE TURNUPS?
>> THEY ARE DOLLARS.
YOU CAN USE THEM TO BUY OUTFITS.
>> SHOULDN'T I BE GETTING PAID
OR SOMETHING.
>> I WOULD ASSUME SO.
THEY HAVE BEEN MAKING THEM FOR
YEARS.
>> WE'VE BEEN PLAYING THEM SINCE
WE WERE KIDS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
IS THAT MY DAUGHTER?
>> YEP.
JUST GIVING STELLA THE BIRDS AND
THE BEES TALK.
>> AND REMEMBER, ALWAYS USE TWO
CONDOMS.
>> THANKS, MOM.
>> HERE'S A TURNIP.
>> I WOULD NEVER SAY THAT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
>> COMBAT MODE.
OUR MOLLYS ARE FIGHTING TO THE
DEATH.
WE CAN ALSO DO THE SKATE LEVEL.
WE JUST LEARNED HOW TO MAKE
TWISTS.
>> 2 K 24 IS SUPPOSED TO BE
FLAWLESS.
>> EMOTIONAL LEVELS ARE LOW.
WE GOT TO GO TO THE THERAPIST.
>> IN COLLEGE I ACTUALLY DATED A
WOMAN.
>> HOW DOES IT KNOW THAT?
>> THIS GAME RULES.
YOU CAN BE ANY MOLLY SHANNON YOU
WANT.
YOU CAN BE A SUPERHERO OR A
RAPPER.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE A RAPPER.
I WANT TO BE MYSELF.
>> I'M TIRED OF GETTING YELLED
AT FOR A HOPBY I HAVE.
SEE YOU LATER, MOLLY.
>> OH, MY -- MOLLY, ARE YOU
PLAYING THE GAME STILL.
>> I BECAME A RAPPER.
>> WHAT?
>> MY NAME IS MOLLY THE RAPPER,
AND I'M REALLY GOOD NOW.
I'M ON LEVEL 99.
♪ SAY MY MOTHER-LOVING NAME, YOU
KNOW IT'S MOLLY SHANNON ♪
♪ DOING HIGH KICKS, AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THE LOVE IS.
GOT MY FINGERS IN MY ARMS, CAN'T
PULL THEM OUT ♪
♪ LIKE A CALIBER, SEASON 25
CALIBER, PUNKS GETTING MARY
CATHERINE GALLAGHER, BITCH.
>> OH, MY -- MOLLY SHANNON THE
RAPPER.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> THAT WAS SO GOOD.
>> THAT'S NOT GATORADE.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> BITCH.